education secretary Julian Keegan is in
the Pro in the studio on the program for
us now good morning good morning good
morning see you as always how many
schools are closed or partially closed
today well we don't know that we'll know
later on today and we'll publish that uh
this afternoon
um we have done a survey which a lot of
heads responded to um so that gives us
some idea and that said the majority it
just said the majority of schools would
be open but we've got yes open but we've
got you know how many are open and how
many open with some restrictions how
many open to to everybody
um obviously we're really disappointed
that any uh closing but um we will know
later on today and then we'll publish
that information okay I was speaking to
uh The Joint head of the Neu Union
um and he's there is that there was not
when he came in to see you the minister
brought no proposals whatsoever to the
table nothing on pay this year or next
no suggestion of non-consolidated lump
sum no pay rise what's the point calling
them in
well we need to continue these
discussions so I've met with them now
since the ninth since the 9th of January
I've met with them three times uh by the
way for over an hour each time they keep
talking about half an hour meeting but
it was an hour and ten minutes that one
um and we've also had two official
meetings one of which was six hours to
go through all of the details you know
we have to keep these discussions open
obviously when you're around the table
it's not going to be you know here's our
inflationary pay rise plus whatever you
know this is not going to happen it
would be irresponsible of us to do that
so what's the point that's coming in
because we need to find where there is
um a a landing Zone really so when you
look at teachers and teachers paying
when you actually look at a teacher's
sort of things that irritate teachers or
things that they want changing it's
always a workload
um Behavior sometimes and other aspects
of bureaucracy as well as looking at
paid to make sure that we can recruit
the very best and retain teachers as
well so what we've said to them is look
we cannot
as a country We cannot put um you know
for some parts of society and inflation
or inflation plus rise which you know
many people are striking for what we
have to do is halve inflation that's the
most important thing or get it even
lower than that and then everybody in
the country will benefit we can't bake
in inflation which is what will happen
if we you know we start to get wages uh
spiraling out of control in inflationary
uh or even more than inflation Rises so
that is the huge Focus for this year but
what we've said to them is you know we
accept and we've worked with them a lot
on Recruitment and Retention challenges
in the past we've said you know we will
look at Future pay we will look at
workload we will look at um flexibility
the teachers also want to look at more
job sharing and flexibility we look at
all of those things that's the point of
calling them in because we can we
believe get something which would be
fair to teachers and we're always
looking to be constructive you know we
we want our children to have the best
education in the world that means we
need to attract people into teaching and
we need to retain people and motivate
people as you know okay but you know the
pointy-headed finance people will say
inflation inflation inflation um The
Institute for fiscal stop studies says
that teachers have seen a 13 real-time
loss in pay six thousand pound pay cut
between 2012 and 2022. it's hardly
surprising they're angry well when they
look you know the independent
pay-per-view body when it looks at all
of this it takes nine inputs it looks at
um pay it looks at other people's pay it
looks at you know retention it looks at
recruitment it looks at inflation looks
of all of those things and comes up with
so just so your your listeners know the
average classroom teacher is paid 39 500
pounds the uh this year the the pay
Rises were five percent for experienced
teachers 8.9 for new teachers new
teachers will be on a starting salary of
30 000 from September 23 that's pet as
per our Manifesto commitment 40 of
classroom teachers this year will be
receiving up to a 15.9 percent rise
because his way as well as the pay on
the on the bans there's also progression
within the bands so it's actually more
complex and it is a quite a complex
picture we've also looked at um
recruitment challenges for example maths
and physics teachers and some of the
chemist chemistry and some of the other
science teachers computer science as
well and we've put bursaries in place
for those we've also put a Top-Up for
some of those schools as well some
schools in disadvantage areas well teach
you know we all every everybody wants to
be paid more you know they're not one is
paid enough I well we look at that we
look at that in terms of recruitment
retention and we look at that in terms
of the starting salary that's why we've
improved the stock starting salary so it
will be thirty thousand uh
well if it isn't we'll look at it again
but we will we have recruited and
attracted a lot of graduates so 30 000
for somebody coming out of University
you know and that's across the country
give me all the figures
um
they keep going on strike we've got uh
several more strikes uh planned if they
don't get what they want um you're
saying strike as much as you want
there's no more money well no what I've
said is it's really disappointing really
concerning this strike is not a last
resort the discussions we had on Monday
were constructive discussions they even
said that at the beginning whilst then
saying I didn't come up with any offers
Etc and that's of course not what's
going to happen I'm not going to just go
in and say here you go we will do
inflation plus whatever
um it would be
economically incoherent to do that we
can't do that and we've made that very
clear but we will get inflation down so
everybody will feel better and then you
know we're just going to run down the
clock until inflation starts no we've
said we will talk about future pay we've
actually held back okay right well it's
already in fact our future pay our
submission was actually due in last
Friday and we we've halted it the next
year that's from April about this year
this is when they want the money well
yes and we've said you know we're
looking at Future pay we'll look at
things like workload but we have said
what are what our objective is this year
is to get rid of the problem which is
inflation and we know why inflation's
there right this is not usual inflation
it's very specific to the war in Ukraine
and the overhang from the pandemic two
highly unusual things that are happening
on our continent and they've affected
every country so we don't want to thank
anybody else's well we don't want to
bake in inflation and we need to get our
economy so that it's better than
everyone else's and I think we can but I
think we can do that you know we Jeremy
laid out his plan and very confident in
our economy I mean you know I've worked
in business before I became a politician
for 30 years in many many sectors I am
very confident about our economy and our
ability so will there be a significant
pay rise next year for them well what we
said is we will look and talk in double
figures no I mean we will look and talk
what is reasonable to make sure that we
always retain the best teachers and we
attract the best teachers you know we
are to have a world-class education
system you need brilliant teachers
that's something we both agree on but
the other thing we agree on is our
children have been through so much
disruption in the pandemic that you know
it really is
um super concerning for children they're
already behind we need to help them
catch up and that is it needs teachers
to be in school to do running out of
time let me ask you about Dominic Robb
should the PM ask him to step back until
the inquire into his bullying is
concluded well I personally think it is
fair to let investigations continue you
know I think that's the fair process so
I I think actually it was Dom himself
who instigated this investigation so
that's ongoing obviously they're going
to uncover all the facts and then when
you get the facts you you discuss them
take the action what's it like for you
as a woman sitting around a cabinet
table with someone who allegedly makes
his staff feel suicidal I you know I sit
around the cabinet table and you know
don't see don't see that right I don't
see any you know I feel very comfortable
with my colleagues around the cabinet
table I think it's only fair when
somebody is you know there's something
like this somebody accuses somebody of
something that you go through a fair
process I think that is the right thing
to do and then the Prime Minister
um and Dominic will obviously discuss
that and make the right decision based
on that you've got to go on the facts
and they're uncovering the facts right
okay Jacob Reese mogg yesterday sat
there where you are and told us that
people are too snow flaking at about
bullying claims well I mean I don't
agree with that I mean bullying is very
serious and actually you know as the
education Minister one of the things
that really is worrying in schools is
bullying and online as well the the sort
of way that bullying can spiral online
is is awful so I don't agree with that
bullying is wrong and people should not
bully anybody it's good to see you thank
you thank you very much for joining us
thank you